Congratulations!
You've reached the end of the course.
Well, the course videos anyway.
Now if you remember nothing else,
here's what I would say is
the biggest idea of this class.
When it comes to algorithm and
data structure design,
there is life after RAM.
In this course,
you lived three such lives.
In the form of PRAMs, distributed memory
machines, and two-level memories.
And of course you'll need, in the
afterlife, hybrid models that mix and
match any of these.
The main point is that there
are ways to formalize and
reason about communication,
which you now know.
So good work, you!
As for what comes next, remember
that this class was mostly about
algorithmic and data structure
foundations, meaning theory.
But there's a whole other side to HBC
which is about how do you make these
ideas actually work on real machines?
Many projects give you a little
bit of a flavor of this but
there's a lot more to it.
It's an especially complex topic and
one which I've wasted,
not wasted, spent,
think positive, think positive.
The bulk of my career thinking about.
So who knows?
Maybe you'll join me in another course
where we can spend some time together
thinking about that.
That sound like a pick up line?
Oops.
Awkward.